If you enter in 2026 with the same
habits, then your life will never
change. Because listen carefully, your
life doesn't transform because of luck.
And it doesn't change because you feel
motivated for one week. Real change
happens because of habits. The small
things you do every single day, the way
you wake up and the way you spend your
mornings and the way you treat your body
and mind. So one tiny habit may look
useless today, but over time it quietly
shapes your future. Because bad habits
slowly destroy your life, but good
habits slowly rebuild your life. So, if
you're serious about transforming your
life in 2026, then please watch the full